franz stock prêtre allemand amoureux de
la france
aumônier des prisons de paris entre 1940
et 1944 il assiste et accompagne au
moins un millier de résistants fusillés
au mont valérien
ce sont d'ailleurs les familles des
fusillés et d'anciens prisonniers qui
lui ont offert cette stèle installée en
eure et loir
jeudi trouvèrent l'histoire de franz
stock en arrivant à chartres et
tout de suite je ne suis une vie comme
ça c'est une bd une bande dessinée pour
mettre en avant l'un des artisans de la
réconciliation franco allemande
jean françois vivier pour les textes
régis parentaux de noël pour les dessins
séduit lui aussi par le personnage en
lisant sa biographie j'ai trouvé
effectivement comme jean-françois qu'il
y avait matière à tout à fait je
visualisais les planches la bd allez ce
soir pour ce qui est déjà un bon départ
et puis voilà puis aujourd'hui c'est
émouvant de revenir sur les lieux que
j'ai dessiné de l'église de recherche à
chartres à l'ancienne caserne du coudray
c'est là que freine stock dirige le
séminaire des barbelés prisonnier de
guerre il enseigne la prêtrise à
d'autres allemands en captivité
entretenue par une association le lieu
est encore imprégnée d'une ambiance
particulière les photos ne suffisent pas
toujours ces berbères
d'apporter d'arpenter les lieux pour
sentir un peu c'est de ressentir une
atmosphère de 1945 à 1947 950 tonnes
sont passés par ce grand bâtiment
tellement froid qu'on l'appelait la
galerie des glaces
franz stock qui a installé à jamais sa
chaleur humaine et cette fresque qu'il a
peint lui-même saint michel terrassant
le dragon
c'est très émouvant de se dire que le
personnage a vécu ici deux ans deux ans
très intense
je trouve c'est très très impressionnant
voilà de se dire au lieu de sophro
milieu de toutes ces responsabilités
qu'il avait qu'il ait pu peindre cette
gigantesque fresque qui est toujours
présente voilà c'est toujours
franschhoek est toujours un peu parmi
nous grâce à cette fresque morts
d'épuisement en 1948 le prêtre a marqué
tous ceux qui l'ont côtoyé
mais aussi ceux qui se sont intéressés à
son histoire dans son testament si l'on
peut dire à ces séminaristes
il ya cette phrase que j'aime beaucoup
qui je pense est vraiment très
représentative de toute sa vie c'est
quand il dit que le nombre de saints
voulue par dieu suffi à sauver une
époque le pape jean xxiii dira de lui
l'abbé stock ce n'est pas un nom c'est
un programme
à méditer